الى جازان مع مراسل صباح العربيه واسامه
القاسم اسامه اهلا بك يسعد صباحك اليوم
احنا مع فطور صباحي ننتقل معك من مائده
المنطقه الجنوبيه اتفضل يا اسامه عرفني
على الفطور الجزائري واحنا معك
والجميع مشاهدي صباح العربيه طبعا اليوم
مختلف في صباح جميل بالتاكيد على رائحه
المائده الجيزانيه التي تعتبر من اشهر
الموائد هنا في السعوديه وايضا انها من
اكثر المواد على الحصول على القيمه
الغذائيه طبعا خلونا في البدايه حكيكم عن
بعض المنتجات والمقتنيات هنا في جازان
طبعا هذه تسمى الدجاجه والدحاجه هي الاداء
التي يتم خض لبن البقر الطبيعي بها وهذا
الزنبي اللي يتم حمل الخبز والحبوب ايضا
في هذه الحيسيه يتم صناعه ايضا بعد
الاطباق فيها وهذه كالحافطه تقريبا يتم
فيها جمع الحلويات وايضا مقتنيات الحبوب
والمخبوزات هذا الفانوس القديم وهذه همم
الطاقيه والطربوش الذي يوضع على رؤوس
المزارعين وايضا كبار السن في اليوم حابين
نحكي لكم ايضا عن الطبق الجيزاني اطباق
الجيزانيه اللي موجوده اليوم في جيزان ما
هو الفاتوره اذاني واساس الفاتوره
الجيزاني في البدايه هنا
حاب احاكيكم عن الخضير اللي هو اساس
المائده الجيزاني ومن اشهر المنتوجات
والمحاصيل الزراعيه هنا في جازان هو يعني
بالتاكيد ذو قيمه غذائيه كبرى جدا الذي
سنتذوق منه اليوم ان شاء الله احد
المنتجات هنا المنتجات
والاطباق الجزانيه الشهيره اترككم الان في
جوله مع المصور حول هذه الاطباق الشهيه
جدا
وقبل ان نتحدث عن هذه الاطباق ونجربها
ارحب بالاستاذ محمد حوبان اليوم وحب اليوم
تحكيني عن هذه الاطباق طبق طبق وحابين
نذوق على الهواء وقبل ما اسالك عن الاطباق
الجيزانيه انا بسالنا هذه السهام نادين
سهام تعرفوا طبق من الاطباق الجيزانيه
اللي موجوده اليوم في السفره
بقى احنا ناويين يغششنا محمد ابو يوسف
محمد الطليحي
اجاوبك يا اسامه فرجيني الصوف
يلا زي ما انتم شايفين اول شغله عندنا
مغشش وحيسيه زي ما احنا شايفين
ههه
عليك وعليها السلام والله انا خاطري يجي
محمد عشان يذوق الاطباق الجيزانيه
بالمناسبه امس اشواق تسالني تقول لي اسامه
كيف السمك اتوكل الصباح قلت لها لا الطبقه
الجيزاني يعني كل الاطباق تنوكل الصباح
والمساء كلها يعني اطباق واحد وكاله الله
يعني خاطري بكره برضو اشوف هذه الاطباق
احنا اليوم مع الاستاذ محمد الاستاذ محمد
اليوم اول شيء نبغى نحكي عن الاطباق ثم
نجربها اهلا وسهلا فيكم اليوم
عيد هنبدا بال- بالحلو طبعا احنا عندنا في
جيزان نبدا بالحلو اكثر يعني يعتبر طبق
المرسى من الاطباق
زي الابيتيزر يعني زي المقبلات الاوليه
احنا عندنا اليوم نوعين من المرسه الدقيقه
رغم انه الخطير الان خلص هذا الاسبوع يعني
همم احنا الان في اخر الموسم بعد كده خلاص
يتوقف الحصاد عندنا كذلك الحسيه الدخن هذا
يضمن الاشياء من الحلو يعتبر على السفره
وبعد كده ندخل على زي ما قلت على الثقيل
يعني عندك القرار طبعا هذا مطبوخ بزيت
السمسم همم الفوم هذا اللي يطلع من من زيت
السمسم يبين انه السمسم جودته جدا عاليه
بعد كده همم عندك السمكه الكنعد مع التمر
الهندي او الحمر اللي احنا نقول له همم في
جيزان همم السمك سمك الكنعد يعتبر من اجود
انواع الاسماك وتشتهر في جيزان متميزه في
ذلك عندنا نحاسيه همم اللحوح يعني تطبخ مع
مع مرقه همم اللحم همم لها مذاق جدا رائع
عندنا المغشات هي من ال- من الاطباق
الجيزانيه الاساسيه تعتبر همم مكونه من
الخضار ومرقه اللحم واجزاء كذلك من من
اللحمه البلدي بعد كده عندنا اللي هو ال-
همم المكشن السمك هذه من الاشياء الاساسيه
جدا يعني في وجبه الفطور والغداء وكذلك
طيب خلينا خلينا بعض الاطباق وخلينا منكد
بدانا في الحلقه برضو نبدا في الحلقه وانا
بصراحه من الناس اللي حب ال- حب المرسف
خلينا نجرب ايضا المرسل اليوم هنا في هذا
الطبق الشهير جدا هنا في في جازان
والمنتجات الاوليه
هذه من اهم الاشياء اللي يعني تحسن من
جودتها هذا الطبق اذا كان العسل او السمن
همم غير اصلي وغير بلدي وغير فيكون الطبقه
جدا جدا
استاذ محمد شكرا على هذا التوضيح همم
اليوم ما شاء الله المائده الجيزانيه
مائده فاخره مليئه بالقيمه الغذائيه ايضا
المذاق الشهيد جدا واتمنى اني اقدر
اساعدكم هنا الجيزان ويتوق هذه الاطباق
سويا ولكن انتقل لكم الاستديو واحنا بجرب
ان شاء الله بعد الهواء
اسامه مائده غنيه يعني كما تبعنا معكم
وتحياتنا لكل اهل الجزائر ولزمينا من جزان
الاستاذ محمد طميحي ومن ذكر كمان انه
بالنسبه انه نتحدث عن الافطار انه جازان
هي موطن رئيسه لبن الارابيكا والاشهر في
العالم كانت السعوديه عام 20 22 عام
القهوه السعوديه شكرا